our next figures once with Scott
what was this
so forward back let's get hot
oh you didn't use it
okay okay
okay so I want to apologize for my
slides because my laptop died over the
weekend and I'm thankful to totally
would lend me his laptop for a few hours
so I could at least recover the figures
but there are no references no text no
labels whatsoever but I hope I was not
confused too much of it yeah I want to
talk about a crisp theory that the
theory that a colleague of mine and in
Bochum has developed sansheng and sort
of contrast this with a standard
framework and I think that to talks fit
nicely to each other so I first say a
few words about this model so the idea
is we have cortical representations that
go through the internal cortex sort of
as an interface to the hippocampus the
main side of storage would be a ca3
which because of its recurrent
connectivity can be conceptualized as a
hopfield network which is an outer
associative memory model the dentate
gyrus is meant to orthogonalize patterns
because if you want to store something
in an optic network the patterns should
rather be orthogonal to each other and
then c1 is sort of a structure that
helps sort of decoding the patterns
again but the actual storage and
retrieval is done in ca3 so we call this
a standard framework and not standard
model because there's not one model that
actually represents this but there's a
whole series of papers by different
people we use here as a reference model
by traversing roads in a particular by
rows 95 so that is one nice complete
simulation of this we use as a reference
so now in contrast the Chris model
proposed by Sen Chiang supposes that the
out the Association of probably recall
of individual patterns so if you give a
partial Q and this then gets completed
to the full pattern that has been stored
that this happens in C a1 through
heterosis ation so in you do out your
Association but
do this in a two-step hetero Association
process so that's done here ca3 the role
of c3 is to provide sequences and here
the idea is that not the sequences are
not stored and ca3 they're already there
so ca3 already has by some
self-organization process sequences in
there and when you store a sequence
actually just associate the patterns
that come from the outside of the
stimulus patterns to this already
existing sequence so that that would c3
is therefore and energizer is a very
similar role as in the standard
framework it's there to orthogonalize
patterns and to disambiguated them or to
put them in context and I want to talk
about two models so the one that
concentrates on the single pattern
recall and the other one on the
association of sequences so this is work
done by tossed Nia in my group together
with sansheng also so here we use pretty
much the the Rhodes model 95 we've
adapted it a little bit so we have sort
of the cell numbers from red physiology
scaled down by a factor of 100
connectivity sparseness is taken from
red physiology skater on by a factor of
10 if you also scale it down by 100
there are no sign ups is left so you
have to scale down by less or there are
too few sign ups is left so this is
number of neurons positive levels taken
literally from from what we know
physiologically so it's an attempt to
sort of have a an abstract model but
that respects some physiology so black
as are shown connections that are fixed
and green are connections that are
plastic and they all follow
sort of hebbian type of associative
rules and it's pretty much exactly what
rhodes does in his model except for that
we use that we've simplified the
dynamics in some sense that we use so
the forward activation is just a linear
sum over the weighted activities here
and then we have a K when I take all
mechanism
to get the sparseness that we have in
these different layers what is the
activity level so here 35% of the
neurons would be active at any given
time here today so these are two plots
from the original paper by roads 95 and
it shows the correlation of the recalled
patterns as a function of the
correlation of the cue so if the cue is
very poor the recoil patterns are also
very poor but if you have feet in
perfect pattern then the recall is good
and on the left side and this is in C 3
this is in C 1 and this is in Android
cortex on the left side you see the
dynamics with recurrent dynamics so you
have sort of the current dynamic and C 3
actually working and on the right side
it's not the other way around without
without recon dynamics and with
recurrent dynamics and you see that the
performance with current with recurrent
dynamics was better as you would expect
at least in CA 3 also and C 1 but in EC
there's hardly any difference so the
quality of patterns that you recall in
this model so inroads model in his
original paper the quality of the
patterns in EC is pretty much the same
whether you use the recurrent
connections in CA 3 or not which is a
bit strange because the recurrent
connections in CA 3 are the essential
concept here right but it doesn't make
any de much difference in the output
layer now we have reproduced this so
this is an attempt to really produce the
results by rolls a green means see a 3
and red see one blue is C dashed line is
without recurrent dynamics and solid
line with recurrent dynamics and you see
here as well that in the EC doesn't
really make a difference whether you use
your current dynamics or not now we have
modified the roads model a little bit by
adapting the sparseness and the
connectivity in c1 to more physiological
levels and then we get this graph and we
continued
work with this slightly modified a bit
more biologically plausible model where
actually makes the difference even is si
will use recurrent dynamics or not okay
so this is again the two plots that you
have seen before the correlations of in
cr3
and and EC as a function of Q quality
with recurrent dynamics and without
recurrent dynamics now you could also
measure the performance of such a system
in a different way namely by saying okay
what's the confusion rate so what's the
probability that the recall pattern that
you get is actually more similar to a
wrong pattern under to the right pattern
so it's not about so much about what's
the quality of the Q but how much do you
confuse it with other ones and if you do
that the performance looks different
then it actually makes no difference
even in C if three doesn't make a
difference whether you use recurrent
dynamics or not so this is on what this
is with random patterns yeah now we
thought well now we know a bit more
about what the input into the
hippocampus is so we could do
simulations with more plausible patterns
so we use grid cell patterns we have
simulated four modules of grid cells and
then the population activity at one
particular location in space right
taking over all these then serves as an
input to the internal cortex eyes and it
was an internal cortex activity and it's
clear that this is called now more
correlated as more structure in it than
random patterns because if you take two
nearby locations then at least for the
for the low-frequency gratings that will
be highly highly correlated right so the
pattern now is a different state
statistics and this really has a quite
significant effect on the results so now
so the same plots maybe I go back to
slides again so this is with random
patterns and this is with these more
plausible correlated patterns and what
you see there's no
difference anymore in so in terms of
correlation and in terms of the
confusion rate also what's the
probability that the correct pattern XJ
is the most similar pattern to the
recoil pattern we see that the recurrent
connections actually are harmful right
so this is this is with recurrent
dynamics this is without the current
dynamics and the performance without
current recurrent dynamics is better
than with recurrent dynamics supposed to
be taking from these graphs I mean
you're saying somehow you're saying that
if they are the same that means the
system is working properly it's a well
first of all so this is a cube quality
so this is what you feed into internal
cortex and this is the correlation with
the correct pattern so that's what you
get out and what if the whole thing
works well as an outer associative
memory will the capability to complete
it so to recall from a partial Q then
you want these curves generally to be up
here right so that's the one message and
here you see the dependence on these on
the Q quality now the difference between
the two curves is whether you use
recurrent dynamics and see a three or
not so either you use CA three as a
hopfield network and you let it settle
and - it's sort of attractor point and
then you go through it or you don't do
this and so these graphs these graphs
show that whether you use the recurrent
dynamics in CA 3 or not doesn't make any
difference in terms of performance and
these graphs show that if you use their
current dynamics actually the you tend
to confuse patterns more so I mean if I
mean there's a standard framework which
is head of a conceptual part right and
the central idea of this conceptual part
is we have a hopfield network and this
hopfield network helps us to complete a
partial Q so if you have a partial Q we
feed it in then the recurrent
connections are essential to recall the
complete Q
that model was wrong that obvious that
the model is actually I mean doesn't do
that right I mean what does wrong mean
in a model right it just says that the
main claim that the recurrent
connections in ca3 are essential to do a
good recall is just that doesn't work in
this model and it it even didn't work in
if you look at it carefully I mean this
curve is pretty much the same that as
this curve even the original roads paper
it didn't work right and now I and the
additional thing that we say here is
that if you use correlated patterns it's
even more severe so it's true the
statistics is really different whether
you use random patterns which are sort
of really favorable for a hopfield
network or whether use correlated so so
this is the pattern of one cell across
space and we have a lot of these cells
and I said when I take the activity of
all the units at one location that's the
way we get the patterns how do you read
out the cute how do I read out the cues
in a feed-forward Network
yes and if you'd forward Network you
just I mean you you you put a pattern
here you let it propagate here and then
you you have a reconstructed pattern in
a hetero hetero Association you you
train a network to do a mapping between
one set of patterns and another set of
patterns and if you if you don't give
the original pattern in the input layer
but a corrupted version hopefully a good
heterosis theta will still reconstruct
the original pattern that has been used
as a target right will show model is a
hetero sensation model that does pattern
completion so you can do pattern
completion in the forward Network it's
just you don't have the constraint that
the input pattern should be the same as
the output pattern so you can associate
any pattern to any other pattern if you
give the partial Q as an input you get
hopefully the complete Q out so from an
experimentalist perspective I would sort
of ask you know so if you took Jim's
data those data are consistent with the
idea that mismatches caused you to come
back to the same pattern does this
network do the same thing because the
space of networks is huge yeah right
yeah sort of know whether we're in a
space of networks that's directly
relevant to the physiology or some other
space of networks yeah I would have to
think about this for some time I mean at
least so the first half of your talk I
think would be completely consistent
with this because the role of integers
is the same C of 3 and C 1 I see some
problems there so one would have to
think about this but I think that a lot
of experimentation I mean this standard
framework is so dominant that I mean
every experimentalist sort of pretty
much is in this mindset okay so we
interpret the whole thing in this in
this way and often you can interpret the
data also in some other way because I
mean we are talking about a structure
that's really deep inside right and
often I mean CMC I mean in physiological
data it's more direct by sometimes even
behavioral experiments are interpreted
in this terms and then you it's not
really clear this in C or 3 is in C 1 or
so so this isn't thing really worth
discussing but I would take this
okay question what are these red lawns
there yes I'm going to so now that we
asked ourselves okay so why does this
happen so to get a little bit more into
this so at the red dots we looked at the
histograms of correlations and that's
what's shown here so for this particular
point we see here in blue and cyan this
is so on okay okay so one histogram
shows in blue and cyan the correlation
between the recoil pattern and the
correct pattern and in red the
correlation between the recoil pattern
and the wrong patterns right and ideally
as you see the correlation with the
wrong patterns would be low and with the
correct patterns should be high in blue
you see those cases where there was one
wrong pattern that actually had a higher
correlation than the correct one right
and please notice there are many many
more entries here than there right
that's why it so this distribution this
is sort of to the power of four where
this is just 50 that's why you have
these blue so many blue ones here okay
so this gives you an idea sort of what
happens on a histogram level now if you
see so this is with recurrent dynamics
with this is without recurrent dynamics
and this is in ca3 and this is in EC and
what you see here is what happens due to
the recurrent dynamics in CA 3 that the
better patterns actually get better and
the worst patterns get worse so the
whole distribution just gets wider but
the mean value does not improve and the
consequence of this larger spread of
correlations is higher confusion because
the left half sort of moves towards the
confusing with the wrong correlations
yeah so this gives a little bit more
insight why you have this parent is
current discrepancy that there's no
difference seen here but there's a large
difference here but that has to do with
the variance of the correlations for the
spread
okay finally we have also simulated a
network and I should maybe go back to
the this one here where we just wear
only these two connections are plastic
everything else is fixed and when we
want us to associate patterns we put a
pattern here and we we do hetero
Association from EC to C a1 and from C
a1 to is C and the pattern with which we
had her associate is generated along
this loop I mean we use this loop now I
mean in principle you could just create
random patterns and see if c1 right and
then you could forget about all this but
this is sort of one way to create random
patterns here yeah and I mean we believe
according to Chris theory that is
important for other things but could
serve serve as a seed for random
patterns and cu1 so what we basically do
is we put our our patterns that we're
going to store here create random
patterns here through this pathway to
hetero sociation and then add recall we
just use this hetero Association based
back and forth right so rather than
having a hopfield network we have a
two-stage hetero Association okay on the
left side is random input on the right
side is the structured grid cell input
this is the correlation in EC and this
is the confusion or the the number of
correctly percentage of correctly
retrieved cues and he'll see the it for
random patterns the correlation is not
so great in is seem the correctly
retrieved cues is is sort of like in the
other cases but if you use correlated
patterns there's really a big difference
so the correlation is slightly better in
this simplified model and the quickly
retrieve views is is much better so
actually with this much more much
smaller model by just using two hetero
associations you could perform can
perform as well or even better than the
full model where the outer Association
happens in Cu 3
if you if you again if you use the
recurrent dynamics it's even worse you
okay so this is the part about sort of
Kris theory modeled with respect to
associating just single patterns so next
I want to talk about storing sequences
and this is done by young major PhD
student in my group again together with
collaboration with Sen Chang so this is
our architecture that we use so this is
what you've seen before we don't have a
CA one in this case we can put it in but
it doesn't really make a difference in
terms of performance for this sequence
storage so what we use as input is
handwritten digits from the MLS database
so it's very convenient well-known
database we train an outer encoder to
compress this about 800 dimensional
input into a 200 dimensional
representation so we take that as a as a
easy representation then we have a
random mapping that's being trained also
but to map random patterns to random
patterns to to a 12 fold increased
representation you see this year this is
a large sparse representation and we
assume that we have an already self
organized sequence in C 3 of random
patterns and so this is 440 units here
and we've stored a sequence of 200
patterns there so that exists and then
in the moment we want to store the
sequence we present the patterns of the
sequence one by one to the input layer
they're encoded into this more random to
see representation then made sparse to
afford them and then these two
connections are the ones that are
plastic by some by a heavy rule you know
with some way T came
from ec2 input that's I mean in the end
we want to visualize how good is the is
the recall and for that we need a
reconstruction so this is sort of mainly
for us it's not really right okay so
starch is clear so we okay this is not I
mean this is this is Karthik this is not
part of the it becomes I mean actually
strictly speaking this is not even part
of their becomes right this is the
entorhinal cortex and this is
hippocampus and this is a very crude
model of the visual system I mean here
retina right and then sort of a
one-layer model of the visual system
okay so these are the patterns that we
store just a random sequence of digits
and it's somewhat difficult insofar as
you're very similar patterns in the
sequence you know okay
I mean the actually two slides you don't
see the difference because one is the
input and the other one would be the
reconstructed output by the auto encoder
so the auto encoder works well okay so
this is now we present a cue which is
happens to be this three here and then
maybe I go back to the architecture so
we present a cue that goes through this
one it triggers a pit on here and from
then on we just let the internal
dynamics run and hope that it actually
has sort of started the sequence at the
right position and then we just we let
the internal dynamics run and then the
feed forward creates us an output and
that would be this one here
and if you compare this with the star
patterns you see that it works fairly
well alright and what I know it does a
correct recall it doesn't do perfect and
I should mention these are those
patterns that have been stalled last and
these are the petals and if we start
first so there's some degradation it's
actually a linear degradation of quality
as the patterns are sort of further in
the past yeah very good question
we have is we have a cyclic sequence of
200 and we start here we let it run
through and then it continues there and
we let it run sort of for one full loop
right so for ease of analysis learning
right now let's just recall the learning
was before when we store the sequence
and that's important thank you for
asking
so during learning each pattern is only
represented once and there's one single
learning step so this is really one shot
storage of a sequence of patterns right
and that's that's essentially in because
usually models that use that one store
patterns in the recurrent connections of
C 3 they present the same sequence a
couple of times that's not necessary
here this is one shot what's the
dynamics of the recurrent FFC three
anybody that's a normal doctor kind of
dynamics sososo
but it's just generating sequences for
this sort of exploring randomly ok so
it's ok so now it's yeah it's you have
some activity
and that with sort of delay of one
determines the activity of a whole
network and the same next steps so it's
really just wandering around in states
but it's not sitting in one spot
no it's generating a sequence just trade
on one series this sequence yes it's
just the 200 pattern sequence and if you
continue training on more sequence then
you overwrite because the internal
sequence only has a length of 200 so
there's so that's the defined sort of by
us defined capacity that you have some
of the counters become degraded if I
understand it correctly just move to the
right on the top row but then they get
sharper again later so you might seem
that correctly like for example the
third pattern after the three looks
pretty degraded yeah so the actually
overall the top level the top patterns
are multi greater than the bottom ones
become more degraded and then less
degraded later that's a property of this
network is but it doesn't ask well
what's maybe important in that context
is so we have an intrinsic sequence in
co3 and and that is very reliable if you
start at the correct pattern then you
really get the true pattern the true
sequence out and it's very noise
resistant sort of its noise zero is
robust with respect to noise so it
really has a tendency to produce
reliable and from then on you just I
mean this is sort of perfect you can
think of this as the first approximation
perfect and the reconstruction then
determines whether it's degraded pattern
or not and earlier patterns are more
degraded and later ones because it has
been long a father away sort of more in
the past that these patterns have been
stalled the fact that it looks like it's
right now more degraded and then so that
either it's just an accident that this
happens to be more degraded could also
be that in the in the c3 sequence you
don't jump directly on the sequence but
somewhere else and it needs some time to
actually converge to the sequence and
that might also
this corrupted version because this is
not a reconstructed pattern that's the
thing that we put in maybe it becomes
clear if you move to the next one so
this is a noisy version and then you see
it's more degraded so it takes a few
steps until the sequence actually I tell
the system converges to the really exact
patterns on the sequence it sort of has
some distance to the sequence and then
it's converging more to to the sequence
yeah we have to finish okay I can just I
think there's nothing really very
crucial I mean there are some errors
about two percent or so of the of the
recalls or failures of the sequence but
otherwise it works yeah okay so this is
not an autonomous system if you like
right so we really by hand saying now
you store and now you recall like in
most other systems so it's so there's no
intrinsic mechanism that decides whether
to store or whether to recall I mean
that's and that's a problem with almost
all models most of the models that you
have to by hand you distinguish a
storage and and recall face I mean my
customer isn't as a model where he
interleaves that it's more an autonomous
way so we would have to combine this
maybe with ideas like that in order to
make this more autonomous so you should
think of the sequence of 200 and entries
more of a sequence of 200 rather unique
entries that might be very similar
because if you use M Ness is this
suggest that it's kind of a sequence
where we sample from ten digits yes
that's not the case actually in the
intrinsic sequence the patterns are all
unique so there's no danger of confusion
there and now if you have a pattern of
unique if you're the sequence of unique
patterns and then you can associate
patterns that might be really similar
and the sequence would still be
able to retrieve that because it say you
have been 200 sequins like it's really
just 10 different inputs right I mean
through an old hand corner and
orthogonalize so this is kind of I
that's right so if I just ten unique
input patterns right yeah yeah then then
speeding at once then should activate
more positions in your yeah then it
would by chance activate one one pattern
in the sequence hopefully and run from
there so whether you feed in this one or
this then perfectly identical one so you
would have an equal chance of stop the
sequence here there there or there or so
right but once it has decided that it
starts here it will reproduce the
perfect sequence
despite the repetitions but here it's
actually the differences that you have
between these two ones is sufficient to
actually jump to the correct I mean the
system does not confuse for some reason
not these but it confuses think this
with with some other pattern also it's I
mean this auto encoder is very sort of
is able to distinguish these fairly well
yeah so if I understand it correctly so
you saying when you did the two-step
heteros efficient has in works better
than the Auto Association business do
you have any insight as to why it's
better what will why why is that
succeeding with a one-step art associate
or fails what's the difference other
than the architect your vote yeah why is
it one better than the other well it's
known that the workshop model has a sort
of better capacity then then the hobby
network but I would have to go into this
and try to know I can't really offer a
good intuition for that like generate a
bunch of hash code but they're just the
but it's a very reliable machine to
generate the sequences and you just you
just basically kind of pointers on by
training on each of these on these
completely reliable to the random and
meaningless patterns
produces them I think
yes and that's a very robust way to do
sequences and I have to say it's
completely to me it's a revolutionary
thing because people have been talking
about you know sequence learning as okay
you see AP CDE and then the network
learns to produce ABCDE I mean directly
through greenberg but it's it is a very
powerful metaphor that I think does has
gripped the minds of people for many
many years so this is a very different
way to do it it would be nice to know
like why it works better or is it just
because it's just super hard to train
sequences in this head not work quickly
and reliably or if you put it in a
sequence it doesn't like you're kind of
stuck and so you'd only produce the
sequences that it likes to produce and
then and then it attaches your stuff to
it yeah we were just starting to do this
yes so this is one of the arguments for
the quiz theory that it naturally
explains the phenomenon of pre-play
pre-play means that you can record from
sort of sequences sort of prior to the
experience i replay is you put into the
read an environment and then later on
the read replays the sequence of
activity that it is experience in the
barroom and sort of and it's sort of it
interpreted as sort of really
experiencing what has happened before
and pre-play is the phenomenon that you
actually find these sequences before
their experience which is a bit strange
right which is logically impossible in
the standard model but this one would
explain this because the sequences are
already there and then they are only
used to associate patterns to it ok one
last question if you want
associate onto this some sequential
structure that's more interesting than
linear structure like that like a
teammate's
structure in space where sequences could
correspond to and it was a joint so the
idea the concept of the Christy REE is
that sort of that the purpose of the
compass is really to store sequences
linear sequences something that happens
in time and things that happen in time
is always just linear right by the
definition and if you if you want to
represent more complicated structure
which is also in some sense connected
but not necessarily sequential in time
because you split off that would be
something that's not been done by the
compass but by more semantic structures
okay
[Applause]